die weltraumstation jahrgang 1 ist
inzwischen auf einer höhe von unter 170
kilometern über der erdoberfläche
abgesunken und befindet sich damit
bereits in der äußeren erdatmosphäre die
dort geben allerdings noch relativ dünn
sie wird also bereits langsam abgebremst
die raumstation bewegt sich seit märz
2016 unkontrolliert auf die erde zu
jetzt ist ziemlich genau bekannt wann
sie abstürzen wird also alles zum
absturz von rang eins wann und wo
schlagen die trümmer auf der erde ein
jetzt den klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen
das ist eine ziemlich große raumstation
nicht vergleichbar media es ist aber
doch schon ganz schön schwer mit 8,5
tonnen
hier nochmal die wichtigsten infos
übersetzt heißt die erste chinesische
nicht dauerhaft bemannte raumstation so
viel wie himmlischer palast sie ist etwa
so groß wie ein linienbus und
ausgestattet mit einem 14 kubikmeter
großen labor sowie einer kleinen wohn
ecke für die besucher von herrn koch 1
in den letzten sechs jahren hat das
raumlabor mehrere kopplungsmanöver mit
chinesischen raumschiffen der zensur
reihe hinter sich gebracht im september
2011 hatte china chang dong 1 ins all
geschickt und jetzt nach sieben jahren
stürzt sich station mit ihren 8,5 tonnen
gewicht auf die erde eigentlich sollte
sie kontrolliert zum absturz gebracht
werden aber dann brach der funkkontakt
ab die station ist nicht mehr steuerbar
und stürzt jetzt eben unkontrolliert auf
die erde schon im letzten jahr war
tagung 1 wohl außer kontrolle geraten
china kann das labor schon seit märz
2016 nicht mehr steuern die folge rang
eins bewegt sich seitdem unkontrolliert
auf die erde zu im oktober kreis sie die
station nach chinesischen berechnungen
wohl noch in einer mittleren höhe von
etwa 3 111 kilometern im mai davor waren
es noch rund 350 kilometer und jetzt
sind es nur noch exakt 167 kilometer
wobei die höhe zuletzt mit zehn
kilometern pro tag gefallen ist also
auch jetzt schon wieder etwas niedriger
sein dürfte das beschleunigt sich in den
nächsten stunden dramatisch bis sie
abstürzt regelmäßig gibt es dazu status
updates aus china ab einer höhe von 200
kilometern wurde die station deutlich
schneller durch den luftwiderstand
abgebremst jetzt gibt es aktuelle
berechnungen wonach teil der
chinesischen raumstation
schon in den nächsten stunden auf die
erde stürzen werden es ist jetzt
ziemlich genau klar die chinesen
schätzen einen eintritt in den frühen
morgenstunden des zweiten april
das ist bei uns ab 18 uhr am ersten
april eine riesige frage aber ist wo
werden die trümmer abstürzen
es ist nicht das erste mal dass wir uns
mit weltraumschrott gedanken machen
müssen weil er auf kollisionskurs mit
der erde ist wieder in
der eine oder andere von euch 1991 viele
bruchstücke des sowjetischen raumstation
207 auf argentinien arab menschen wurden
zum glück nicht verletzt weltraum
experten und expertinnen fordern ja
immer wieder dass ausgediente stationen
und satelliten direkt im weltraum
recycelt werden anstatt zieht weiter
mehr oder minder unkontrolliert auf die
erde stürzen zu lassen fest steht für
tiangong 1 die station ist nicht mehr
steuerbar und stürzt jetzt ab dabei wird
ein großteil verglühen aber 30 prozent
wahrscheinlich nicht alles was aus
edelstahl oder titan gefertigt ist wird
unweigerlich auf der erde landen und
größere brocken generatoren motoren und
so weiter wahrscheinlich auch zwei bis
drei tonnen dürften das im fall von
tiangong 1 seien
fest steht dabei nur dass dabei ein
feuerball aus den auseinanderbrechenden
teilen entstehen wird wo das genau sein
wird ist immer noch unklar und sieben
stunden vor dem eintritt in die dichte
erdatmosphäre können in einem ersten
schritt wahrscheinlich kontinente und
städte ausgeschlossen werden aber
weiterhin heißt es von expertinnen und
experten das risiko von einem
trümmerteil getroffen zu werden ist
extrem gering zitat die
wahrscheinlichkeit von einem trümmerteil
verletzt zu werden ist so hoch wie die
möglichkeit zwei mal in einem jahr von
einem blitz getroffen zu werden so
holger krag von der esa also nahezu
unmöglich bislang wurde noch kein mensch
von einem trümmerteil getroffen die
station umrundet die erde in nur 90
minuten sie legt also in der minute mehr
als 400 kilometer bezogen auf die
erdoberfläche zurück das heißt dass nur
wenige minuten darüber entscheiden wo
sie genau herabstürzt nur eins ist
sicher hier in deutschland sind wir auf
keinen fall betroffen auf mallorca
könnte sie stürzen denn sie pendelt über
der erde zwischen dem 43 grad südlich
und dem 43 grad nördlich und überall
zwischen diesen beiden breitengraden
kann die raumstation abstürzen für die
weltraumagenturen weltweit ist der
absturz auf jeden fall ein glücksfall
sie können ihre tracking systeme
ausführlich testen und so in zukunft
absturzopfer von trümmerteilen genauer
bestimmen immerhin fliegen achtung 7500
tonnen weltraumschrott um die erde
sobald sich etwas genaues weiß welches
euch auf whatsapp schicken da erreichen
euch die nachrichten ja sofort und gar
wenn ihr also nichts verpassen wollt
dann endet meine telefonnummer hierbei
whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir auch
vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
garantiert und zur begrüßung gibt es ein
kleines goodie von mir einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das
aber mit der genau glocke vergessen hier
geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken weltraumschrott das ende
der raumfahrt droht klicks um
science-fiction immer wieder spannend
finde ich mal sagen ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran